you're gonna have to forgive me we're
going bare-bones today because I've had
an exhausting day I do not have the
energy to put up the green screen and
everything else but I did just see the
new Doctor Who so I still got to talk
about it listen I don't think there's
anything that makes me happier than when
Steven Moffat goes scary and just from
the cold open on this show to the way it
pans out to stuff at the end that I'm
still fully wrapping my head around but
not in a it doesn't make sense way but
in IE I'm not done unpacking this story
kind of way I just think this was an
excellent episode just from its initial
premise of the sort of notion that are
we ever really alone and how would we
ever know if there was something that we
just are meant to never ever see now
that may sound in a lot of ways like
familiar ground Moffitt's kind of mind
that sort of thing before between you
know the weeping angels that we can't
look away from to the silence that we
see but we can't remember to the fashion
of Narada which is just the darkness so
it's in that same sort of wheelhouse but
it's it's a new twist on the idea and
just the doctor and the way he explains
the idea it's it's unnerving it makes
you go woo which is a great start for
any Doctor Who episode the interesting
thing about this one is really how much
it reveals about the doctor despite the
fact that actually spends quite a bit of
time with Clara and actually with Danny
pink to Clara in this episode about as
good as I've ever seen her and I'm
liking not only Danny pink as a
character but the way we're getting to
know him and it feels like we know him
really well already despite the fact
that this is only the second episode
he's appeared in it's very interesting
the way in which the episode uses time
with these other characters to tell us
more about the doctor about Peter
Capaldi's doctor in particular I just
want to come back I love the dynamic
that he's got with Clara right now that
she's not travelling with me but he's
just stopping him when he's got
something going on that he really wants
to bring her in on and this doctor is
obsessive like the doctor always tends
to be a little bit he'll who get his
head on something and he won't let it go
but previous doctors Matt Smith
especially seemed dead yeah kind of have
a Dede a little bit he was easily
distracted not Peter Capaldi
he is he's got his mind on this and he
is not gonna let it go it is also a
little bit of insight of kind of what
happens the doctor when he's on his own
too much you know not just in the notion
that we've seen before of him
having adventures but a steady campaign
because we've kind of seen that but when
he's literally just him alone in the
TARDIS what goes through his head where
does his mind go what sort of thoughts
and notions and ideas does he entertain
when there's nobody around for him to be
impressive to the episode doesn't spend
very much screen time on that notion but
we really get little hints and nuggets
of it and it's it's great depth
especially for this new version of the
doctor that we're still getting to know
but I feel like we just plumb so much
depth with him in this episode and it's
a difficult one to try and explain
especially if you're keeping me spoiler
free which I always do unless I tell you
otherwise but it's dealing with this
notion of shared dream shared nightmares
and sort of starting from a basic
question have you ever get that feeling
on the back of your neck oh yeah
everybody gets that why not just why do
you get that why does everybody get that
that's just a simple basic question is
the sort of leaping off point that
Doctor Who just works so well with I
can't really go into details keeping
this spoiler free but just the way
things in this episode tie into things
and and like I said the insight and the
doctor the way things pan out at the end
again I'm still fully wrapping my head
around what it was I actually saw but
but unless I miss something massive I
don't think I'm gonna be suddenly
disappointed once I do fully wrap my
head around this episode I loved it as
just a watching experience and as the
more I think about it the more I'm
enjoying it it really wrote a fine line
in terms of maybe giving us almost too
much insight into the doctor but just as
Moffat has done teasingly with episodes
like the name of the doctor the day of
the doctor ease he's really ridden the
line of almost giving us more
information than we really should ever
have but he doesn't quite give it to us
and it's a really fine balance I guess
that's about it
great stuff top-notch unnerving so I
kind of addressed this question for
myself when I did my list of villains
but what for you is the scariest or
creepiest or most unnerving episode of
Doctor
that you've ever seen whatever it is
share it down on the comments and let's
talk about it until next time this
council is adjourned